what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so you guys knew is only ever a
matter of time you knew it was a matter
of time before this came out too
powerful for Marvel movies Franklin
Richards now Franklin Richards is God
that kid is broken
I mean he's he is he is so
astronomically broken it's not even
funny
I mean he's it's it's crazy so so those
you guys don't know Franklin Richards is
the son of Reed Richards mr. fantastic
and Susan storm The Invisible Woman of
the Fantastic Four and his his powers
are off the charts now he has a weird
history there right like he got back to
Fantastic Four annual number six or two
or one it is and Franklin Richards makes
his debut and the idea behind this was
that a Franklin Richards was basically
siphoning off the life energy of Susan
storm while he was in the womb and so it
took Johnny Storm
and it took Ben Grimm the thing and it
took Reed Richards going to the negative
zone and basically capturing the cosmic
control rod which is the negative zones
this will really do not understand a
whole lot about it it's the negative
zones version of like the power Galactus
has like the power cosmic
and it was wielded by a guy named
Annihilus and that was the first time
Annihilus learned about the Fantastic
Four which ultimately led to the events
of annihilation when Annihilus invaded
the main Marvel Universe with an army of
like billions of bugs and almost destroy
the entirety of the universe they took
Galactus just like annihilating to
Thursday annihilation wave and just
being like you're done before like
before before and I listened then
basically retreated but ya know okay so
sort of so for Franklin once Ben and
Johnny and Reed came back with the
cosmic control rod they basically used
that to kind of like balance the energy
of Franklin and then Susan Susan gave
birth to her son naturally now for the
longest time Marvel attributed the the
powers of Franklin Richards to the
cosmic control rod basically saying he
was like he was like like a second
Galactus the issue with this is that
well not really an issue with it um it
was we're just kind of a cut change it
was just a total switch and this came
out of the 198 files and this was
basically a story well not really a
story it was kind of a story basically
what happened as a skullet which went
crazy she distorted reality she said
everything back and when she did she
said no more mutants and so there were
only like a hundred ninety-eight mutants
left but what they did is they created a
one-shot now I'm sorry maybe was a
miniseries it was called the 198 files
and it basically listed like the most
prominent of of the various mutants and
it described Franklin Richards to being
a music it has signed him to the mutant
population and said well he was Omegan
level and so it was the first time that
really happened and that kind of shifted
him away from having his powers tied in
the cosmic control rod and said he's
actually a
now for the most part Marvel kind of
toyed with that a little bit you know in
the in the in-between years from like
when Franklin first showed up all the
way to the 198 in 2005 whenever that
story came out the most notable was Days
of Future past and days of future past
as most people know was a story where
the signals took over the earth and I'm
sorry took over in North America and it
ended with basically a nuclear strike
from like the world's superpowers on to
the US wiping out the Sentinels
but during that story Franklin was
captured and he had a mutant containment
device that was strapped around his neck
to keep his power shut down and so at
that point the only powers he really had
was like telepathy and telekinesis and
that was that was really it so it gets
kind of finicky when you get into that
that sort of thing that was one of the
things about Claremont's x-men is it was
really more people borrowing stuff from
Claremont's men then Clairmont borrowing
stuff from other people because it was
one of those things where what he was
doing was working so well he didn't have
to borrow anything from anybody else but
the fact remains here for Franklin as a
kid his powers were pretty basic like
they were they were pretty simple and
what I mean by that is he would have
like these small little moments in time
the biggest thing that came out during
the early days of his character was in
Fantastic Four number 245 well Fantastic
Four number 245 and then Fantastic
Four's number ten from 1995 but in issue
number 245 of Fantastic Four basically
the way this played out is Franklin's
powers they were never really kept in
check because there was never really any
need to worry about the extreme nature
his powers because I never really flared
up or manifested but in that story he's
trying to solve a puzzle
and he's frustrated by the fact that he
can't solve the puzzle he's like a
little kid and there's this commercial
that comes on in the background on the
TV and it says why don't you just grow
up and so in his frustration his powers
flared up and when they did he aged
himself into an adult but didn't know
who he was and so you know Susan storm
comes back home but like the whole place
is in shambles right like somebody had
gone through it it looked like they just
like ransacked the place and like torn
everything up and she ends up finding
this guy who basically looks like a
blonde Jesus if Jesus was blond that's
what he looks like the character was
called avatar and so as the stories for
us story progresses you actually end up
realizing it's Franklin Richards who
aged himself up and so when everything
set back to normal Reed Richards put
mental blocks in place so Franklin's
powers would never manifest and
occasionally they did occasionally they
would flare up one of the most notable
instances after that again you know
going in a fantastic force number 10 he
basically started spawning like all
these different versions of himself and
and like it turned in this crazy
situation ah but the most notable
really went into you earlier there were
two no two more notable events the first
one was the onslaught saga and the
aftermath so like heroes reborn and then
the second one was the Abraxas saga and
the Abraxas saga was like 2001 it was in
the early 2000s 2001 2002 2003 but
onslaught was in the mid 1990s and the
way this played out was you basically
had the mental powers of Xavier and his
frustration with humanity's refusal to
accept mutants that basically merged
with Magneto's hatred for humanity and
then it just turned into like this
psychic entity so during that story
Franklin Richards was absorbed by
onslaught and then of course it took
like it took apocalypse and cable
traveling into the body more or less you
know intellect of the form of onslaught
and then trying to retreat Franklin only
for us to find out that apocalypse went
in because he saw Franklin as a new host
and so he wanted to take over the body
of Franklin Richards and the cable was
gonna try to stop him Susan storm was
apparently followed him she was
invisible the whole time she followed
him and then got Franklin out of there
before apocalypse could do anything and
then that leads into like the all the
super heroes you know like like Jean
Grey suppressing the Bruce Banner
persona The Incredible Hulk freaks out
punches a hole through through onslaught
and like all the characters that weren't
selling jumped into onslaught and and so
they were all basically dead so like for
a lot of the Avengers the Fantastic Four
basically everybody with the x-men
essentially and like spider-man and so
so like although all the characters just
that were crappy and weren't selling
they all basically jumped into our slot
and they were reborn in the heroes
reborn universe but what you ended up
finding out is Franklin missed his
family so much and missed the
superheroes around him so much that what
he did is he be basically created a
pocket universe in the form of like this
blue ball that he would carry around and
inside that universe was heroes reborn
so he basically resurrected them all and
then put them in a different universe
and so at the end of that story he's met
by a celestial and she basically says
like you have to set everything back you
have to choose one earth or the other
you can't have both and so Franklin
chose to basically take all the
character from the heroes reborn bring
them back into the main Marvel Universe
and then destroy the heroes reborn
universe it was crazy
from there you going to the Abraxas saga
and Abraxas was the answer to the
question what would happen if Galactus
died and so when Galactus in the main
Marvel Universe dies you end up finding
out he's the gatekeeper for the
representation of the multiverse is
destruction which came in the form of
Abraxas and Abraxas literally disordered
like hopping and skipping through every
single universe and killing every
version of Galactus he found and so from
there like they ended up taking Franklin
Richards
he resurrected Galactus from the dead
and then Galactus turned the ultimate
nullifier on Abraxas the ultimate
nullifier was this device but if a
person was powerful enough where I'm
sorry if they they had enough like focus
they could destroy anything in existence
and so the Franklin had like like his
kid version had like these little
moments where he would pop up and he
would have like these powers that would
just kind of occasionally appear and do
a thing and then that would really be
yet now that goes into Jonathan
Hickman's run on the Fantastic Four so
whenever you see people talk about Kent
Franklin beats such and such then that's
basically they're talking about the
version of Franklin Richards from like
Hickman's Fantastic Four so the way this
unfolded is is the Fantastic Four
I've told the story a million times and
I'll tell it a million more times the
way this whole thing happened is you
have the Fantastic Four who was sitting
at sitting at home do whatever they were
doing and the alarms and everything
start buzzing and it's like what in the
hell is going on and and like there's
just like this grizzled old guy that
appears in the house and like oh my god
he's going for the children it's like
dude okay some guy with a man bun shows
up in our house and he's got like a
beard he looks he looks like he he looks
like a vagrant alright and like he shows
up in our house and he goes to the kid's
room this cannot be anything but bad and
so like the guy puts up a force field
that none of the Fantastic Four can get
through and like Susan storms like the
queen of forcefields right she's like
the first lady of Marvel so it was like
if anybody can get through this force
field you can Susan and she's like I'd
love to but I can't and so like so
they're just kind of stuck behind there
and so like Franklin ends up wandering
out into the hallway trying to figure
out what's going on the adult version
like picks him up whispers something in
his ear and then drops him down and
Franklin passes out and so then he goes
into Valerie's room Sesame to her and
then leaves and then everything goes
back to normal but what you end up
finding out in backup Ichie backup
issues for future foundation I think was
the backup issues in that one is that
this was the adult Franklin Richards
from the future and in the future Reed
Richards is going to die and so the
adult Franklin was trying to find a way
to keep his father alive and knew that
waking up the powers of his younger self
was the only way to do it so that's why
I went back to the Past woke up the
powers of his younger self and when
Franklin when when little kid Franklin's
powers wake up he basically starts
creating universes in his bedroom like
whole universe is under the blanket in
his bedroom most kids are sitting on the
blanket hiding from monsters Franklin's
creating universes so the adult version
of Franklin starts coming back to the
past like visiting into the past and
teaching his younger self how to use his
powers and that's when you really get
like this full-on display of what
Franklin can do in the sense that what
they do is they basically create like
this whole universe it's just a totally
empty space and young Franklin starts
going through and just creating things
creating like solar systems and life and
planets and stars he basically becomes
God and just like starts creating all
these different things which is how it
is
Franklin was able to like assemble
universes and throw them out there at
the end of Secret Wars I don't mean if
you guys knew about that but that's best
that explains that's why you can you can
just read Jonathan's runs in its
entirety like alone you literally start
from Fantastic Four Dark Reign you run
all the way up to when he finishes
Fantastic Four Future Foundation then
you stop then you jump into vendors and
New Avengers and it's all just one
seamless story but anyway so younger
Franklin learning how to use his powers
the whole basis behind this was it goes
into this great big huge fight at the
end go go watch my videos on Hickman's
Fantastic Four if you want to see the
whole thing but it goes to this great
big huge fight between Galactus and
these Celestials from a different
universe now these alternate realities
Celestials called the mad Celestials
destroyed Galactus and so then like
Franklin valaria come from the future
and you end up finding out that what had
happened was when the older Franklin was
teaching his younger self how to use his
powers it was that he could basically
take all the energy he had all his power
that he'd been gaining over the years
and then consolidated all down save it
and then give it to his older self and
so adult Franklin is running around with
like twice as normal power level and
he's doing insane things but he he
destroys a celestial in one punch and
it's just like dandy went straight at
Rocky Balboa he resurrects Galactus
again dude it's it's like the most
badass seen Galactus is dead like as
soon as he gets a powers from his
younger self he's like rise and like
raises Galactus like Toby Michael act
it's like raising resurrect like you
from the dead it's just like holy it man
is one of the coolest things it was
hilarious too because there's one point
where the mad Celestials believe they
defeated Franklin Richards and so like
like when they analyzed and misses he'd
like they're like he's a universal
constant like he's beyond omegan level
and Franklin's like yeah man like you're
you're kind of screwed and it's kind of
funny because like like like there's
Commons the others there's like
commentating at everything just steel
from L press the door for second it's
like do massive a you didn't beat him
you just pissed him off and now you
because now he's gonna destroy all you
guys I guess that's exactly how it goes
like like like Franklin restaurants
collages from the dead and between the
two of them like he he starts
controlling to like just like a puppet
like he's controlling Galactus after
resurrecting him from the dead and like
deta start like just annihilate these
mad Celestials and the fights over in
like this it's maybe like a like a
minute and a half long and like these
mad Celestials are totally obliterate
who frankly is so powerful I mean the
power he has is absolutely insane I mean
like I said it's funny little things
though like like during Fantastic Four
Dark Reign
when Norman Osborn the Green Goblin
became like the new director of shield
he storms the Baxter building and
Franklin's standing there with like a
toy gun and he's like you need to leave
and Norman's like you can't tell me what
to do and Franklin goes to pull the
trigger on the toy gun and shoots him
with a real bullet and it's like damn
stuff like that now for the MCU you
could never have Franklin Richards in if
you could but the only role he'd be able
to play is just this son of read that
CEO like he just be a kid who's there
because if you did that you'd run into
the exact same problem you have in
Marvel Comics where everybody starts
asking the question well why doesn't
Franklin just fix everything now here's
a huge distinction to also pick up too
so in Marvel Comics when it comes to
like reality Wars it's not just one type
right like you have different types of
people on that level but they're split
into two camps you've got reality warper
and then you've got matter manipulators
and they're two distinctly different
things but their powers are also really
similar so if if I set you down and I
said okay like here's some clay go ahead
and make a thing out of it if you said
well I want to make a horse and you made
a horse out of that clay or you say I
want to make a cow and you made a cow
out of that clay you're a mater
manipulator and Marvel Comics you know I
mean relatively speaking but you guys
understand the principle you're taking
what you already have and you're turning
it into something else
people like Matthew Malloy like Scarlet
Witch when she had the power of cathode
classic dr. strange Franklin Richards
with that level of power a reality
manipulator would be like if I put you
in the same scenario with that clay and
you said well I need more so you just
created it out of thin air that's what
reality warbirds do they they control
the fort leh they literally manipulate
reality in such a way that they can do
anything they want they can create
something out of nothing they can break
the laws of physics you know because
laws of physics say that matter can't be
created or destroyed like if you die
your atoms go somewhere the people who
are reality warbirds can defy all that
that's why the Infinity Gauntlet and the
Cosmic Cube are so powerful because
they're not bound by the laws of physics
they can do anything they want and so
that's what Franklin Richards does
Franklin Richards is not a matter
manipulator he's not constrained by the
by the fundamental forces or the form
and function of a universe he can do
anything he wants he can change the
universe and his powers got got advanced
enough if he knew how to harness them
well enough I mean he's done stuff like
that like he formed he created a box out
of thin air that would basically keep
the voice of Black Bolt from like
destroying him I mean it was it's just
little things like that if you guys
don't know what that means don't worry
about it black balls party and humans in
the inhumans suck so it's just small
little things like that uh but Franklin
is it's crazy powerful in the in terms
of his abilities but you couldn't have
him in the MCU because literally people
would just ask the question why does it
Franklin just fix everything why doesn't
he just like snap his fingers and fix
everything
why doesn't he just you know Accio
everything being corrected you know and
just you know fix it that way you notice
like transfigure the university just
make Harry Potter real which i think
would be awesome
it's like Franklin Richards in the MCU
and he was watching the Harry Potter
movies and he's like I want that to be
real and just like manifest Hogwarts out
in like
England or Scotland wherever the hell it
is out there there's like makes it in
like like that would that would be
amazing you know and then like like I
would even throw a little interview in
there with JK Rowling's like how does it
feel to know that like your stories have
come to life it's like coming on I guess
it's cool sorry like I'm too busy
arguing stupid things on Twitter like I
mean I don't I don't know like I have no
idea what would happen so this this
franklin richards is just too powerful
for the for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he's just way too ope there's
there's no way to make him work there's
no conceivable way to make it work
because it's just an insane level of
power you have to nerve him down now
they could do things like give until I
Betty and telekinesis and just say hey
as like really high levels of telepathy
and telekinesis he's on par with like
Jean Grey as the Phoenix or something
along those lines but frankly is more
powerful than that so the people who are
fans of Franklin will front will
probably get kind of angry about it you
know they probably feel a little bit
betrayed but I mean I would really here
I just want to see Franklin in the MCU
but it gets kind of bonkers I don't know
any real feasible way because even fan
OHS with the Infinity Gauntlet it's like
a fraction of the power he has a Marvel
Comics like half those fights in
infinity war should have been like five
seconds long like they never should have
been that long they just shown up like
that five seconds three of those or
Thanos like showing up and then people
going to attack him he's just like nope
and then that's it and then they're done
they could turn to gel out or just get
sent back in time by like 60 million
years but then again it would have been
like the most boring movie ever
right like technically speaking the
entire plot to infinity war could have
been done in like half an hour and in
like one Avengers movie well you could
have done all that Thanos just like
shows up I mean honestly I think that
probably have been better if they had
done like the entire plot to infinity
work if they just condense it all down
to half an hour interested yep that's
how powerful Santos is but he just
walked into earth just walked in to the
home of the Avengers they're like man
you gotta get out of here Thanos so
they're fighting Asia sleep like lambs
to the slaughter you know just just
taking him out you know like I just just
absolutely reckon him good just go off
freezer just be like I'm only using 1%
it might have it yeah it'd be kind of
cool to see to be honest I think it'd be
kind of Awesome
anyway we rambled on long enough if you
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]